SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google,
and I'm very lucky to
be joined by Kelsey
Hightower, the greatest
person that I know.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Ooh, I'm putting
that on my performance review.
SAAD ALI: That's right.
Kelsey, can you
tell us what you're
most excited about at
KubeCon here this year?
You've been to a
lot of KubeCons.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
We have 8,000 people here,
and what I'm noticing is
some people still don't
know what Kubernetes is.
So keeping that
fresh perspective,
I can learn how we should
be making it better, what
the real problems are, right?
I haven't had to manage
production infrastructure
in a few years now.
So it's kind of nice to know
what the real problems are,
keeping grounded.
And just learning from
other people, right?
So a lot of us considered
us experts, right?
You're expert in
the storage space.
But then there's
things-- use cases
we don't know, so
the opportunity
to learn from the community.
SAAD ALI: Yeah.
So I mean, I've heard a lot
from you about customer empathy,
not necessarily worrying
about the engineering problem,
but taking time to
think about, what
are the problems that we're
actually solving for customers?
And in that
perspective, you've been
asking us to take a step
back from Kubernetes
and look at the problem
more holistically.
Can you talk about
that and what Google's
been doing in the
past few quarters
to actually address that?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
So I think the Kubernetes
team, in particular-- any team
that's doing engineering
work in the open,
you start to have empathy for
all the issues that get opened,
right?
But for me, I get fortunate that
I get to go see our customers
and whiteboard.
And very rarely do we
start with Kubernetes
as the solution or the problem.
It's usually we want to do
these five or six things.
So internally-- you've
been a part of them--
we do these empathy sessions.
And the goal is to
take our engineering
and say, let's feel it the
way our customers feel it.
And then we actually start
to see that, you know what?
Without even
mentioning Kubernetes,
we all have ideas of how
to solve these problems.
It's bonus points if we
can leverage a platform
like Kubernetes to solve them.
So I think it's more of, how can
we make more people successful?
Sometimes that
involves Kubernetes,
or sometimes that involves
a new thing, like Istio,
to solve that kind of problem.
So that empathy
session is what helps
me stay grounded and focused
on what the customer needs.
SAAD ALI: So as you
talk to customers now,
what are the
problems that you're
seeing them encounter
that we really need
to address as a community now?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Honestly,
I think it's the principles,
right?
CI/CD has been a good
idea for a long time.
It isn't just a good idea
because Kubernetes just
came out.
So what I try to
ask them is this.
What is your culture?
What is your change
management process?
That's what you're
going to build
into this concept called CI/CD.
It's not about Spinnaker
versus Jenkins.
Pick one.
Once you pick one, you're going
to articulate your culture
in that.
I tell people, you're going to
write a set of batch scripts
in a specific order, and that's
how you're going to do things.
If you're using raw VMs,
that will still work.
When Kubernetes comes in, you
can eliminate a lot of stuff
that you do in between
CI and Kubernetes,
and then that's the business
thing that you focus on.
But then the platform
stays the same.
Whether you're using Cloud
Functions, Kubernetes,
or raw VMs, most developers
can just check in code,
and you hide that complexity.
That, to me, is the principle
that has never changed.
I'm telling companies now,
you need to get that done.
Do not kick that
can down the road.
Yes, Kubernetes is awesome.
Has a lot of great technologies.
But if we just go out and hand
out kubectl out to everyone,
we're kind of regressing back
to the old ways of doing things.
Put CI/CD on top, and
just enjoy the fact
that you're going to have to do
a lot less glue between CI/CD
and Kubernetes.
SAAD ALI: So that's great advice
for developers or companies,
to start focusing
on CI/CD first,
and let everything
else evolve from there.
Do you have any other advice
for customers, especially those
with a lot of
legacy applications,
and how they should
deal with them
and think about
this modern world?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: It's funny.
Every customer I meet
and they say "legacy,"
I say you're not
allowed to say "legacy."
You have to say "classic."
Because it's the legacy stuff
that's paying your paycheck,
right?
Like, that's where
it comes from.
This is the tried and true.
So if you consider
it a classic thing--
SAAD ALI: An antique.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: --then
you kind of appreciate
it a little bit better.
So what I tell them is a lot
of the things that are working
will probably also
work in the new world.
It's just about what
do you adapt, right?
So in my keynote, it's funny,
I'm going to be using Fortran,
right?
This is one of the original
programming languages.
Recently had a release in 2018.
And I'll be using that
to deploy to Kubernetes
and other serverless
platforms, just
to show people it's not about
legacy versus new things.
It's more about we've learned
things in the last 30 years.
A lot of them are baked
into tools like Kubernetes,
and here's how you leverage
them with some of your existing
stuff.
Sometimes that's a rewrite.
Sometimes it's a retrofit.
So I want people to focus
more on the principles.
Those last forever, even
if the product changes.
SAAD ALI: And do they need to?
Do they need to
modernize at all,
or is that an option, to
stay put where they are?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So when I
think about modernization,
if you have an app
that you've neglected--
you've not updated it,
you haven't patched it,
you're using outdated software
that hasn't any more support--
you're vulnerable.
There are security reasons
why you need to update that.
It's not even about
modernization.
You need to stay on top of it.
So software is a liability.
Once you write some
software, it's yours.
And you got to
nurture and feed it.
So whether you decide
to leapfrog and say,
you know what, if we're
going to make adjustments
to this to improve
security posture,
maybe we adapt
containers, and that gets
us there a little bit quicker.
So to me, the
modernization is more
about there are new
things available that
were not available
before, and how are we
going to leverage them?
And then label that
whatever you want.
But to me, you still need to do
that, regardless, for security,
just so you know how it works.
But yeah, leverage
some of the new stuff.
SAAD ALI: That makes sense.
So security is a very, very
good reason to not stay
put because you will become
a target very quickly.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes.
SAAD ALI: OK.
That makes sense.
So looking forward
into 2019, what
are you most excited about?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I think
2019, we're starting to settle.
I've been looking at the
Kubernetes release notes.
Not a lot of big
bang new features.
SAAD ALI: Yeah.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So we're
starting to stabilize.
And as we stabilize,
in 2019, I think
we have more people
saying the same things.
Everyone knows what
a container is.
You know what a pod is.
We're kind of starting
to understand networking.
But we're also
starting to understand
where the value line is.
This is where Kubernetes stops.
This is where Istio takes over.
Here's where CI/CD plays.
Here's where serverless starts.
Like, Native has
given people kind
of this clear line of starting
to think about this functions
as a service kind of thing.
So I think 2019, we're
going to start to, now,
get a return on value from this
big open source investment,
right?
You've been working
on Kubernetes forever.
I've been involved
for a very long time.
And when you start
to look at it,
it's like, when do we start
getting a payback on this?
So now people using GKE
don't even think about it.
Oh, there's a security
vulnerability.
Click.
We've upgraded it for them.
SAAD ALI: That's right.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So now,
we're starting to see return
on investment in 2019.
And now, we're
going to also start
to identify what's
missing, right?
We know what we can do
in Kubernetes to improve,
but there's a whole layer
between just run my code
and what Kubernetes does.
That's 2019.
SAAD ALI: That sounds wonderful.
So just to wrap things up,
let's talk about KubeCon.
I'm going to put you on
the spot a little bit.
What's your favorite KubeCon
memory of all the KubeCons
that you've been to?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: You know what?
The very first KubeCon
was purely community.
SAAD ALI: Yeah.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
There was no CNCF yet.
There was no big sponsors yet.
SAAD ALI: This was
in San Francisco.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah.
It was just a bunch of
people that got in one spot,
and we were all betting.
It wasn't the
number one platform.
We were still like, is
Docker Swarm the way to go?
Is Mesos the way to go?
So we got in that
room and we said,
hey, here's what we're doing.
Here's how we're trying.
And I remember, I think Michelle
Noorali posted the Twitter
thing, how many
people are running
Kubernetes on production?
And we had them all get
on the stage, right?
And all of them could probably
fit right here if we tried to.
And that was a very
authentic conference, right?
It was like everyone--
you had to buy in.
And now, when you
zoom forward, you
can kind of see those
people are still here.
So we knew that we built
a very strong community
in the very
beginning, and that's
why I can never forget that.
SAAD ALI: I think one of the
big reasons that Kubernetes
is the scale that
it is now is because
of the community
that it nurtured
and the leadership that came
from the bottom up, basically.
And I think you played
a large part of that.
Thank you, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Awesome, thank you.
SAAD ALI: All right.
Take care.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]